Yesterday, the Council held its monthly meeting
for July.
First on the agenda, was the renovation of
the Oxford Museum and Jaycee Building.
The Council approved a new entrance and toilets
for the building with a budget of $125,000,
with $15,000 being contributed by the Oxford
Museum.
The new entranceway will access the Museum
from the carpark on the western wall of the building.
The Council also approved the Draft Kaiapoi
Town Centre Plan for public consultation.
This document, will for the first time, plan
for the future of the Mixed-Use Business Areas,
formerly residential redzone and find ways
to integrate them into the current Town Centre.
The consultation will be widely advertised
in Kaiapoi and nearby townships and is expected
to take place over August.
The multi-use indoor sports facility took
another step forward yesterday as Councillors
approved staff to engage architects Warren
and Mahoney and quantity surveying firm, AECOM.
After the design phase is underway, the Council
will put the procurement and construction
stages out to tender, with completion of the
facility targeted for the end of 2020.
Councillors also approved contracting out
the operations and maintenance of Southbrook
Resource Recovery Park and Oxford Transfer
station to a private waste business, with
the option of having a community group manage
the resource recovery activities.
This is similar to the existing contracts,
however it will also allow the council and
contractor to partner with a community organisation
to reduce waste.
The Council was also updated on the rollout of the expanded Your Choice Kerbside Collection service.
In the coming weeks, owners of properties
in kerbside collection areas will be receiving
a card which will allow them to select which collection service they would like for their property.
The service is expected to start operation
from July next year.
The next Council meeting will take place on
Tuesday 7th of August.